[Music]
well father because of that blood we
were saved one day and claimed Heaven as
our
home
Catherine
Catherine so we praise you tonight in
Jesus name amen in the
blood the body in the blood the body in
the blood the body in the blood the body
in the blood in the blood cine body in
the blood body in the blood the body in
the blood body in the
blood
stop you know that I love you you know
you can tell me
anything what were you and Catherine
doing out there in those wood
I wanted to talk to
Mama sometimes I hear her
voice you light a
candle clear your
mind you start speaking what the spirit
says to you what does the spirit say to
you leave me alone now
[Applause]
and Angela where is
she Angela where is she
where is
[Music]
she she knows who I
am where's the other
girl didn't care her at home that's not
a good
idea
she's waiting for
you there are many dark Forces in this
world Mr
Fielding not all of them are
Supernatural I wake up every morning
wondering where my daughter is praying
I'll see her sweet face again one of
these
days there's something I saw in your
your book that made me come here today
they took some photos in the
hospital I want to help my daughter like
you helped
yours like you helped
Reagan my daughter is not herself right
now Dad it's happening to my daughter
too Mama I don't feel very
good following in the footsteps of Linda
Blair is an extraordinary
Quest violent
Tantrums spewing of evil
things I don't think there's anything
more
terrifying good day he be home by dinner
I love you good morning Mr Fielding
morning
Catherine Angela and Catherine are
friends their families in a sense are
opposite of each other wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with them Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood were so afraid
that we wouldn't like get along I
introduced myself I'm like hi like
instantly we clicked oh yeah you have to
deal with a bunch of crazy people trying
to make a movie give me just quick
little peekaboos and go to school and
sit in a makeup chair for 2 and 1/ half
hours a
day I remember seeing it and just
thinking wow and that's kind of when it
hit me I was like Dodge
Rock one girl lives one girl dies what's
better than one possessed girl but two I
mean it's just it's insanity they made
me believe it they made me feel it I was
completely taken in I don't want to go
to
hell don't be
scared we've met before
for are you looking for rean are you
looking for rean he runs in
[Music]
hell what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams and a desire to be happy
Dad something's going on with my
daugh it's happening to my daughter too
the devil has one wish Wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with
them to make us lose faith I believe you
can help get our daughters back to kill
it in us and the devil never gives up
she knows who I
am where's the other
girl she is waiting
[Music]
here what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession come on baby come back to us
okay if you don't make it I don't make
it mama what is it baby I can't can't
you I'm right here I don't want to go to
hell God BL that drink on
you they're two haries is it working
they're beating in
syn be
strong what did you
do one girl lives one girl dies you get
choose
[Music]
[Applause]
you have some experience with
position yes more than I'd like an
exorcist movie creeps under your skin
and gets you we pick up the story of
Victor and his daughter Angela a man
who's raising his daughter alone he be
home by dinner I love you good morning
Mr are fing Angela and Catherine have
been friends they're both at the age
where they're just finding themselves we
and Catherine doing out there in those
woods they're just walking and
walking their families in a sense are
opposite of each other Victor's put
church and Faith behind him the other
parents have faith they have Community
wherever those girls went they brought
something back with them the film is
dealing with the vulnerability of
Parenthood with a child that's dealing
with possession have you ever seen any
anything like
this no but there are people out there
who
have playing a character that I created
50 years ago I thought she's had 50
Years of Living who has she become Ellen
Burston really blessed the project Chris
mcneel is going to have her first
confrontation with a demon in many years
don't be scared we've met before
mother it's a terrifying thing thought
you can be taken over by a force that's
inside there have been possessions
throughout
history it's not just in one location or
one religion or one culture it's
universal one girl lives one girl
dies God play and trick on
him
[Music]